This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If you've wandered at Machu Picchu or Stonehenge or the Colosseum or even snuck into that abandoned house on the edge of town, you know the power and a piece of decrepit architecture. Even if you haven't been to these places, they've been photographed and filmed for you. Abandoned Soviet bus stops, deserted old movie theaters, decaying residential streets, they're fascinating in this like planet of the apes kind of way. So of course, there's a German word for it. Ruinenlust, the longstanding aesthetic obsession with decay. Resident Germainophile and producer Avery Trouffelman. It might actually be one of those made up German words, it probably is. But the concept itself is totally a real thing. Ruins inspire wonder.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。如果你曾在马丘比丘、巨石阵或罗马斗兽场漫步，甚至溜进过镇边那座废弃的房子，你就会明白破败建筑所蕴含的力量与魅力。即使你没去过这些地方，它们也早已被拍摄成照片或电影呈现在你面前。废弃的苏联公交车站、荒废的老电影院、衰败的住宅街道，它们以一种类似《人猿星球》的方式令人着迷。当然，德语里有一个词来形容这种感觉：Ruinenlust，即对废墟长期以来的审美痴迷。常驻德国文化爱好者兼制作人艾弗里·特鲁费尔曼。这可能确实是那种杜撰出来的德语词，很可能就是。但这个概念本身绝对是真实存在的。废墟激发了人们的惊叹。
They give the mind this task of reconciling what's there and what's not. What once was and what now is. People flock to remainders of ancient civilizations. Romans, the Mayans, the Egyptians, but people also flock to things that just look like they're ancient too. That combination of decomposition and romance makes a perfect cocktail of repulsion and allure. And for San Francisco's, this place is Sutro Baths.
它们给大脑布置了一项任务，去调和眼前所见与所失之物。曾经是什么，现在又是什么。人们蜂拥至古代文明的遗迹。罗马人、玛雅人、埃及人，但人们也蜂拥至那些看起来很古老的事物。这种腐朽与浪漫的结合，构成了排斥与诱惑的完美鸡尾酒。对于旧金山人来说，这个地方就是苏特罗浴场。
My friend Austin brought me there one night. So how do you get in? Does the trail just lead right to it? Yeah, yeah yeah yeah there's steps there's a parking lot up there and steps to go down head to the rocks at lands end on the very northwest corner of San Francisco walk down the flight of stairs into a grassy slope that hugs the sea off to the right is the gaping mall of a cave to your left is the crumbled foundation of a concrete structure. It looks like a giant Belgian waffle, about 7 feet tall and 50 feet wide on the longest
我的朋友奥斯汀有天晚上带我去了那里。那么你是怎么进去的？小路是直接通向那里的吗？是的，是的，那里有台阶，上面有个停车场，然后有台阶往下走，前往旧金山最西北角的“大地尽头”岩石区，走下一段楼梯，进入一片拥抱大海的草坡，右边是张开大口的洞穴，左边是混凝土结构的坍塌地基。它看起来像一个巨大的比利时华夫饼，最长的一边大约有7英尺高，50英尺宽。
side. Beside the waffle are two pools of still water, with a concrete jetty between them that dares you to walk its length. Make it to the end and you are at a sea wall, where the pacific ocean crashes into the rocks. There's no fence, no guards, only a warning sign that says danger. Cliff at the surf area extremely dangerous. People have been swept from the rocks and drowned. What you can see down here are the ruins of the bath houses.
华夫饼旁边有两个静水池，中间有一条混凝土防波堤，引诱着你走完全程。走到尽头，你就站在了海堤上，太平洋的海浪拍打着岩石。这里没有围栏，没有警卫，只有一个写着“危险”的警告牌。悬崖和冲浪区极其危险。曾有人被从岩石上卷走并溺亡。你在下面看到的这些就是浴场的废墟。
Have you heard any rumors as to what was what here? Strangely no. I mean, other than it's a bath house in San Francisco, with all that I might indicate. Well, not the kind of San Francisco bath house he's thinking of. If he's thinking of what I think he's thinking of. But we'll get back to that in a minute. And last time you were here was just like, were people wondering about the history of it at all? No, it was like 300 bucks in a cave.
你有没有听说过关于这里曾经是什么的传闻？奇怪的是没有。我的意思是，除了知道它是旧金山的一个浴场，以及它可能暗示的一切之外。嗯，不是他想的那种旧金山浴场。如果他想的是我以为他想的那种的话。但我们一会儿再谈这个。你上次来这里的时候，人们对它的历史感到好奇吗？不，当时就像是洞穴里的300块钱一样。
Austin had seen a band playing in the cave. They plugged their amps into a generator that they brought themselves. He told me things like that were happening at Sutobats all the time. And it's easy to see why. This place has a draw. The night that I was there, a group of photographers was snapping shots of the moon. Is this like a known photo destination? I would say the last three years has been more common, so I think people are finding out about it.
奥斯汀曾见过一支乐队在洞穴里演出。他们把扩音器插在自己带来的发电机上。他告诉我，类似的事情在苏特罗浴场时有发生。这很容易理解原因。这个地方有一种吸引力。我去的那个晚上，一群摄影师正在拍摄月亮。这是个著名的摄影目的地吗？我想过去三年里变得更普遍了，所以我认为人们正在发现它。
I just know that in the like the 30s it was some sort of bath for people to sit in and just soak, I don't know if it was hotter cold or what it was about. Ruins have drawn people to them for centuries. Starting the late 1600s, a tradition emerged among European men of means to go visit sites of antiquity. Paris, Venice, Rome, and learn about the roots of Western civilization. Today, lots of people visit what's left of the old world. People like ruins. It gives us a sense of time passing, maybe a sense of place. Why do people go to ancient Egypt?
我只知道在30年代，它是一种供人们坐着浸泡的浴场，我不知道是热水还是冷水，或者它是关于什么的。几个世纪以来，废墟一直吸引着人们。从17世纪末开始，欧洲富裕阶层中出现了一种参观古迹的传统。巴黎、威尼斯、罗马，去了解西方文明的根源。今天，许多人参观旧世界的遗迹。人们喜欢废墟。它给了我们一种时光流逝的感觉，也许还有一种地方感。为什么人们要去古埃及？
Why do they go to the Acropolis? A sense of time go on by, a sense of timelessness. And I think also that urge to try to explain what people are looking at. Anytime you go out to suit you a bit, I mean, there's people crawling all over the ruins I can't. But the thing about these ruins, at the edge of the continent, they may look ancient, but they really aren't at all. You're talking, you're all trying to figure the place out. What is this? What are these tunnels do? What's this thing? There's a curiosity to it. They know their
为什么他们要去卫城？一种时光流逝的感觉，一种永恒感。而且我认为还有那种试图解释他们所见之物的冲动。每次你去苏特罗浴场，我的意思是，到处都是在废墟上爬来爬去的人。但关于这些废墟，在大陆的边缘，它们看起来很古老，但实际上一点也不。你一直在谈论，你们都在试图弄清楚这个地方。这是什么？这些隧道是做什么的？这是什么东西？这里有一种好奇心。他们知道它们是
ruins, maybe if they know they need Sutro Bans, they know they were swimming pools, and that's about it. This is historian John Martini. Martini wrote a book about this place called Sutro's Glass Palace, so named because this pool of water used to be underneath an enormous glass structure. And it was the pet project of Adolf Sutro. The name Sutro might sound familiar to you, especially if you live in San Francisco. There's Sutro Tower, Sutro Heights. There's a Sutro library at the San Francisco State University,
废墟，也许如果他们知道它们是苏特罗浴场，他们知道它们曾经是游泳池，仅此而已。这是历史学家约翰·马蒂尼。马蒂尼写了一本关于这个地方的书，叫《苏特罗的玻璃宫殿》，之所以这样命名，是因为这个水池曾经位于一个巨大的玻璃结构之下。这是阿道夫·苏特罗的宠物项目。苏特罗这个名字你可能很熟悉，特别是如果你住在旧金山的话。有苏特罗塔、苏特罗高地。旧金山州立大学还有苏特罗图书馆，
all named after this one German immigrant. He struck it rich by engineering a mining tunnel during the Nevada Silver Strike in the 1860s, and he turned his money into San Francisco real estate, a lot of real estate. Some historians estimate that at one point Adolf Sutro owned one-twelfth of the city. Adolf Sutro was to San Francisco with John D. Rockefeller was to New York, and what Henry Huntington was to LA. Sutro built public gardens, presented free concerts, and built the structure that would eventually become Sutro Bats. Sutro's original idea was that he wanted to build a giant outdoor aquarium that would
都是以这位德国移民的名字命名的。他在19世纪60年代内华达州白银热期间，通过设计一条矿井隧道发了财，并将他的钱投入到旧金山的房地产中，大量的房地产。一些历史学家估计，阿道夫·苏特罗曾一度拥有这座城市十二分之一的土地。阿道夫·苏特罗之于旧金山，正如约翰·D·洛克菲勒之于纽约，亨利·亨廷顿之于洛杉矶。苏特罗建造了公共花园，举办了免费音乐会，并建造了最终成为苏特罗浴场的建筑。苏特罗最初的想法是建造一个巨大的户外水族馆，
be filled by the tides and it would empty at low tide. So in 1884 he created a catch basin that refilled naturally as the waves broke in. And then Sutro kept making more and more plans, adding on and on to his aquarium. He built the network of swimming pools, connecting canals, he even built a powerhouse as a freestanding building to heat the water. Then when all that was done, then he hires an architectural firm.
由潮汐填充，并在退潮时排空。因此，在1884年，他创建了一个集水盆，随着海浪拍打自然重新注水。然后苏特罗不断制定越来越多的计划，不断扩建他的水族馆。他建造了游泳池网络、连接运河，甚至建造了一个独立的发电厂来加热水。然后当这一切完成后，他聘请了一家建筑公司。
Assembly would be like, if some crazy self-improvement guide built the foundation for an elaborate house, but didn't know what the house was going to look like, he just built a foundation, and he plumbed it. And then you hire an architect to come in and make a building fit on top Well, it was already there. That's how the baths were designed from the outside Sutro baths looked like an ornate palatial greenhouse
组装起来就像是，如果某个疯狂的自我提升指南为一栋精致的房子打下了地基，却不知道房子会是什么样子，他只是建了地基，并铺设了管道。然后你雇了一个建筑师进来，让一栋建筑适配在上面。嗯，它已经在那儿了。这就是浴场的设计方式，从外面看，苏特罗浴场看起来像一个华丽的宫殿式温室。
Underneath its majestic three-tiered glass canopy were several different swimming pools hot water and cold Saltwater and fresh and there were more than 500 Individual changing rooms beneath the sweeping arena-style bleachers. An attached to the baths was a museum full of sutra's crazy collection of stuff from around the world. miniature boats, model buildings, taxidermy to animals, gems, mechanical figures, a real Egyptian mummy, all inside of a glass palace facing the ocean at the edge of San Francisco. Up the hill, towards the road, was a street called Maryway. There was a Firth Wheel, basically a Ferris Wheel, along with a rollercoaster and a hall of mirrors and games of chance. And keep in mind Sutro was building at the edge of nowhere on the rocks by the sea.
在它雄伟的三层玻璃天篷下，有几个不同的游泳池，热水和冷水，咸水和淡水，在宽阔的竞技场式看台下有500多个独立的更衣室。浴场还附设了一个博物馆，里面装满了苏特罗从世界各地收集的疯狂物品。微型船只、模型建筑、动物标本、宝石、机械人偶、一具真正的埃及木乃伊，所有这些都在旧金山边缘面向大海的玻璃宫殿里。在山上，朝向道路的方向，有一条叫“中途路”的街道。那里有一个“弗斯轮”，基本上就是摩天轮，还有过山车、镜子迷宫和机会游戏。请记住，苏特罗是在海边岩石上的荒凉之地建造的。
In public transit didn't go there, and this was a challenge for both construction workers and for customers. It lost money from the day it opened. It was a huge white elephant. It cost eight off Sutro about a million dollars when it opened in 1894. And you put that today, that's the thing. $37.40 million. It couldn't make money from the charging people
公共交通不到那里，这对建筑工人和顾客来说都是一个挑战。它从开业那天起就一直在亏钱。这是一个巨大的“白象”工程。1894年开业时，它花费了阿道夫·苏特罗大约一百万美元。换算成今天，那是相当大的一笔钱。3740万美元。它无法通过向人们收取
10 cents to get in, or in 15 cents to go swimming. It would have had to be packed almost every day. And in an attempt to pack the house, Sutro poured even more money into electric rail lines that led out to the bats. This was a huge boom for the city's mass transit. At the same time, remember, he owned all the land surrounding it that people were going
10美分入场费或15美分游泳费来赚钱。它几乎每天都得爆满才行。为了让这里爆满，苏特罗投入了更多的钱建设通往浴场的电力铁路线。这对城市的公共交通来说是一个巨大的推动。同时，请记住，他拥有人们将要经过的所有土地，
to be traveling through, and there were always advertisements for the Sutro Land Company where they tried to sell land. So he's doing things for the public at the same time trying to make some money. But Sutro Bats just never ever made money. By the time Adolf Sutro was elected mayor in 1894, his beloved baths were still not turning a profit. When he died four years later in 1898, his family started looking to get rid of the property. The Sutro family tried four years to sell Sutro Baths, while also trying valiantly to make
而且苏特罗土地公司总是打广告试图出售土地。所以他既在为公众做事，同时也在试图赚钱。但苏特罗浴场从来没有赚过钱。到阿道夫·苏特罗1894年当选市长时，他心爱的浴场仍然没有盈利。四年后的1898年他去世时，他的家人开始寻求处理掉这处房产。苏特罗家族尝试了四年时间出售苏特罗浴场，同时也英勇地试图让
it turn a profit. In 1934 my father was hired by Adolf Sutro who is the grandson of the pioneer Adolf Sutro. Just about that time Adolf Sutro wanted to do something to get more people out here. If you go to Sutro baths you may run into Tom Bratton. My name is Tom Bratton and now I volunteer for the National Parks, and come out here once a week and for a few hours and talk to people and let them know just exactly what all these ruins were about. Tom's father was an engineer, and he helped Sutro Baths undergo its really witty midlife
它盈利。1934年，我的父亲被先驱阿道夫·苏特罗的孙子阿道夫·苏特罗雇佣。就在那时，阿道夫·苏特罗想做点什么来吸引更多人来到这里。如果你去苏特罗浴场，你可能会遇到汤姆·布拉顿。我叫汤姆·布拉顿，现在我为国家公园做志愿者，每周来这里几个小时，和人们交谈，让他们确切地了解这些废墟的由来。汤姆的父亲是一名工程师，他帮助苏特罗浴场经历了它那非常机智的中年
crisis. They cut off the bottom pool, cut that off from the regular pull, drained that, scatter sand around on it, put in some tables, ping pong tables and picnic tables, and they called that the tropic beach. The tropic beach was supposed to be a warm sandy place in Dora's just to hang out, even though the real beach was right outside. Then it really didn't work out too well. Which really is a shame, because right outside the beach is freezing and usually foggy. A tropical version isn't that crazy.
危机。他们切断了底部的游泳池，将其与常规泳池隔开，排干水，撒上沙子，放了一些桌子、乒乓球桌和野餐桌，他们称之为“热带海滩”。热带海滩本应是一个室内的温暖沙滩，供人消遣，尽管真正的海滩就在外面。但这并没有起到太好的效果。这真的很可惜，因为外面的海滩很冷，而且通常有雾。热带版本并不那么疯狂。
And so they said, well, how about this? We'll take that traffic beach away and we'll put a platform there and we'll make that into an ice rink. And when Tom was in high school, his father got him a job working at this very ice rink. Yes, Tom worked at this place while it was still standing, which seems impossible given how ancient the ruins look. People will really come up to me and say, were these really ruins from Rome? And I say, not really. Not at all. Tom's just being nice. By the time Tom was employed there, the name of the place had changed from Sutro Bats to just Sutros.
于是他们说，好吧，这个怎么样？我们把热带海滩移走，放一个平台，把它变成溜冰场。汤姆上高中的时候，他父亲给他找了一份在这个溜冰场工作的工作。是的，汤姆在它还屹立不倒的时候就在这里工作过，考虑到这些废墟看起来有多古老，这似乎是不可能的。人们真的会走过来问我，这些真的是罗马的废墟吗？我说，并不是。一点也不是。汤姆只是很客气。到汤姆在那里工作时，这个地方的名字已经从苏特罗浴场改成了“苏特罗”。
The Sutro family had finally gotten rid of this place in 1952. When entertainment tycoon, George Whitney bought it. Whitney was the boss when Tom Bratton started as a locker attendant. And even more than the Sutro family, George Whitney was really trying to do everything he could to get people to come out. So he tacked on more amusement, including a ride high above the sea that shuttled between the two cliffs on either side of Sutro's. He called it the Sky Tram.
苏特罗家族终于在1952年处理掉了这个地方。当时娱乐大亨乔治·惠特尼买下了它。惠特尼是汤姆·布拉顿开始担任更衣室管理员时的老板。而且比苏特罗家族更甚，乔治·惠特尼真的在尽一切努力吸引人们前来。所以他增加了更多的游乐设施，包括一个高悬于海面之上，在苏特罗浴场两侧悬崖之间穿梭的缆车。他称之为“空中电车”。
The Sky Tram, this thing had hold about 20 people. It took about 20 minutes to go across. So they didn't eliminate, make a lot of money on it. Whitney also thought an aviary might bring in the big money, so he ordered some exotic birds and some cages. What happened was all the birds came in at once before the cages, so they had the Whitney quelled all the employees and said, okay, everybody here take a home, take home a bird until our cages come in and then we'll bring the birds back.
空中电车，这东西大约能容纳20人。往返大约需要20分钟。所以他们并没有从中赚到很多钱。惠特尼还认为鸟舍可能会带来大钱，所以他订购了一些珍奇鸟类和一些笼子。结果是所有的鸟在笼子到来之前就一次性运到了，所以惠特尼召集了所有员工说，好吧，大家每人带一只回家，带回家养着，直到我们的笼子运到，然后我们再把鸟带回来。
What a mess. But even after the ice rink and the aviary and the sky tram, people still weren't coming to Sutro's. The Whitney's after struggling for 14 years decided we're going to sell the property. Historian John Martini, again. It was sold to a land developer who began to demolish it. And in June 66, that's when the very convenient fire broke out. In 1966, a mysterious fire broke out and reduced
真是乱套了。但即使在溜冰场、鸟舍和空中电车之后，人们仍然没有来到苏特罗。惠特尼一家在挣扎了14年后决定卖掉这处房产。历史学家约翰·马蒂尼，再次登场。它被卖给了一位土地开发商，后者开始拆除它。1966年6月，那场非常“方便”的火灾发生了。1966年，一场神秘的火灾爆发，将
two-trows to a pile of rubble. The no-one was arrested. And then, two-trows was just never rebuilt. Eventually, the last owner sold the land to the National Park Service in 1980. So it's part of a big national park area. Sutro baths is right inside Golden Gate National Recreation Area. And when the government finally bought it, it was seamlessly included into this big national park area.
苏特罗浴场烧成了一堆瓦砾。没有人被捕。然后，苏特罗浴场就再也没有重建。最终，最后一位所有者在1980年将土地卖给了国家公园管理局。所以它现在是一个大型国家公园区域的一部分。苏特罗浴场就在金门国家游乐区内。当政府最终买下它时，它被无缝地纳入了这个大型国家公园区域。
It's not a national park itself, and it doesn't look like it belongs within the Golden Gate National Park's conservancy at all. It just looks like a bunch of ruins. Sometimes ruins are more evocative than if the site is restored, because there's more sense that this is the real deal. Even though these are only 45 years old, they have the same attraction that urged try to explain, but what people are looking at. So unlike other ruins, remains of Sutro baths were less than 50 years old. They are part of a national park. Since 2012, they do have their own tiny museum and gift shop on site right along Maryway where the midway used to be.
它本身不是一个国家公园，看起来也不像是属于金门国家公园保护区的一部分。它看起来只是一堆废墟。有时废墟比修复后的遗址更具感染力，因为人们更有这才是“真家伙”的感觉。尽管这些废墟只有45年的历史，但它们具有同样的吸引力，促使人们试图解释他们所看到的东西。所以与其他废墟不同，苏特罗浴场的遗迹不到50年历史。它们是国家公园的一部分。自2012年以来，它们在现场确实拥有自己的小型博物馆和礼品店，就在曾经是中途路的地方。
The street sign is still there. And yet, the ruins are still pretty dangerous, and to many people, still there. And yet the ruins are still pretty dangerous and to many people still mysterious. So at this point you may be wondering how to get out to the baths or about parking availability or maybe if you can go hold your photo shoot there. Jill can help. People write to me with can I have my wedding there? How can I get there? Can I film my movie there? I answer all their questions. Jill Corral runs sutrobaths.com. And I don't say like, oh, I'm just this random chicken Seattle. From Seattle.
街道标志还在那里。然而，这些废墟仍然相当危险，对许多人来说，仍然很神秘。所以此时你可能想知道如何前往浴场，或者停车位情况，或者也许你是否可以在那里举办摄影活动。吉尔可以帮忙。人们写信问我，我可以在那里举行婚礼吗？我怎么去那里？我可以在那里拍电影吗？我回答他们所有的问题。吉尔·科拉尔经营着sutrobaths.com。我不会说，哦，我只是西雅图的一个随机路人。来自西雅图。
You know, I just respond to their question. Like, yes, is your wedding party smaller than 30 people? Sure, you can have it there. Jill snagged sutrobaths.com in 2000. I couldn't believe that the domain was available when it was. If you contact sutrobaths on Facebook or Twitter, those accounts are also run by Jill in Seattle. I love it when people ask me, like, how much does it cost? Can I get in? It's just like, just go. It's never closed. And unlike Tom Bratton or John Martini, who actually both experienced Sutro Baths when it was a functioning building,
你知道，我只是回答他们的问题。比如，是的，你的婚礼派对少于30人吗？当然，你可以在那里举行。吉尔在2000年抢注了sutrobaths.com。我简直不敢相信那个域名当时竟然可用。如果你在Facebook或Twitter上联系苏特罗浴场，这些账户也是由西雅图的吉尔运营的。我喜欢人们问我，比如，要多少钱？我可以进去吗？我就说，直接去就行了。它从不关闭。与汤姆·布拉顿或约翰·马蒂尼不同，他们两人都曾经历过苏特罗浴场作为功能性建筑的时期，
Jill first encountered the place as a ruin. I was flown out to San Francisco for a job interview in 1997. My main mission was to touch the Pacific Ocean that day before my interview. I went down there and I stumbled on this just insane playground of concrete and metal sticking out of the ground. I didn't know what the hell it was. It was just pretty much the closest to a magical place I'd found as an adult. And I fell in love. I think I will toss my ashes there after I die. Well, I won't. Someone else will. Jill actually did bury her two pet
吉尔第一次接触这个地方时，它已经是废墟了。1997年，我飞往旧金山参加面试。我当天的主要任务是在面试前触摸太平洋。我走到那里，偶然发现了这个疯狂的混凝土和金属游乐场，它们从地面伸出来。我不知道那到底是什么。这几乎是我成年后发现的最接近魔法的地方。我爱上了它。我想我死后会把骨灰撒在那里。好吧，我不会。别人会撒的。吉尔实际上确实埋葬了她的两只宠物
lizards there. They're in the cave. The story of Sutro Baths didn't exactly shape history. Yes, it helped expand San Francisco public transit. Yes, you can see the ruins briefly in a scene in the movie Herald and Mod, but ultimately it was a strange glass complex at the edge of the ocean that was destined to fail. And amusements and attractions were constantly added and removed throughout its life. But in a city as rapidly gentrifying as San Francisco, in a country as young as the United States, these ruins are an anomaly. I respect people's desire for it to be like this mysterious, unknown thing. But when I hear tours talking and just
蜥蜴在那里。它们在洞穴里。苏特罗浴场的故事并没有真正改变历史。是的，它帮助扩展了旧金山的公共交通。是的，你可以在电影《哈洛与慕德》的一个场景中短暂看到这些废墟，但归根结底，它是一个注定要失败的、位于海洋边缘的奇怪玻璃建筑群。在它的一生中，娱乐设施和景点不断地被添加和移除。但在旧金山这样一个快速绅士化的城市，在美国这样一个年轻的国家，这些废墟是一个反常现象。我尊重人们希望它成为某种神秘、未知事物的愿望。但当我听到导游谈论并
sting their wondering like I have been known to walk up to them and tell them like there used to be this giant beautiful magical thing here like you have to know about it. Always read the plaque right? You got it. In addition to researching what the baths were, Jill keeps tabs on how they're changing. Ruins seeing static like a fixed, but of course they're not. I have watched it continue to fall apart. There used to be a deck that you could go and read on by the cave, and then it just crumbled into the sea sometime around 2005.
表达他们的惊叹时，我有时会走过去告诉他们，这里曾经有一个巨大、美丽、神奇的东西，你们必须了解它。总是要读牌子，对吧？你说对了。除了研究浴场是什么，吉尔还关注它们是如何变化的。废墟看起来是静态的，好像是固定的，但当然不是。我看着它继续分崩离析。曾经有一个平台，你可以在洞穴旁阅读，然后它在2005年左右坍塌进了大海。
It's still living and dying in slow-mo. Which is a process the parks are actually trying to stop, according to Tom Braden. As far as the National Parks go, they want to make it so that it's not going to deteriorate any more that it already has. If it deteriorates any more, you're not going to really be able to tell what it really was. Tom speculates they might do this by adding more signs, maybe stabilizing some of the decaying structures, but not too much more. Well, what the parks really don't want to do, they don't want to make it look like a box to go inside and look at the ruins and then come out again. But recently the young
它仍在慢动作中生存和死亡。据汤姆·布拉顿说，公园实际上正试图阻止这一过程。就国家公园而言，他们希望确保它不会再进一步恶化。如果它再恶化下去，你就真的无法分辨它曾经是什么了。汤姆推测他们可能会通过增加更多的标志，也许加固一些腐朽的结构来做到这一点，但不会再多做太多。嗯，公园真正不想做的是，他们不想让它看起来像一个盒子，让你进去看一眼废墟，然后又出来。但最近这些年轻的
ruins have become something else entirely. Nature's reclaiming the site. The ruins continue to evolve. The old swimming pools themselves have become partly silted in. It's become a wetland, migrating birds love the site. And recently an otter appeared swimming in Sutro Bats, the public dubbed him Sutro Sam. Sutro Bats continues to be a machine for generating new San Francisco folklore. Today, Sutro Bats is pretty much back to where it started. All that remains is the foundation, including the original catch basin that Adolf Sutro
废墟已经变成了完全不同的东西。大自然正在收回这片土地。废墟继续演变。旧的游泳池本身已经部分淤积。它变成了一片湿地，候鸟喜欢这个地方。最近，一只水獭出现在苏特罗浴场游泳，公众称他为“苏特罗·萨姆”。苏特罗浴场继续成为生成旧金山新民间传说的机器。今天，苏特罗浴场几乎回到了它开始的样子。剩下的只有地基，包括阿道夫·苏特罗在
built before ever imagining a swimming pool, a tropic beach, a carnival midway, an ice skating rink. So after all the years of building this palace of wonder after adding games and rides and oddities, trying and failing to draw the public out to this strange place by the ocean. All Adolf Sutro or George Whitney had to do was let it burn down and crumble into ruin. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Avery Troubleman With Sam Greenspan, Katie Mingle, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 Local Public Radio KALW, in San Francisco, and produced in downtown
想象游泳池、热带海滩、嘉年华中途路、溜冰场之前建造的原始集水盆。所以，在建造这座奇迹宫殿多年之后，在增加了游戏、游乐设施和奇珍异宝之后，在试图吸引公众来到这个海边奇怪地方却失败之后。阿道夫·苏特罗或乔治·惠特尼所要做的，就是让它烧毁并坍塌成废墟。《99%隐形》本周由艾弗里·特鲁费尔曼制作，山姆·格林斯潘、凯蒂·明格尔和我罗曼·马斯参与。我们是旧金山91.7本地公共广播电台KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心制作，
Oakland, California, out of the offices of Arxan, an architecture firm who values collaboration so much, they could have even worked without off-sutra. If you like more cool tidbits about design or random jokes in the middle of the night, try finding us on Facebook, Tumblr, and Twitter, but if you're one of the hundreds of thousands of people who are kicking themselves because they missed the Kickstarter and would love a 99% visible t-shirt with a razzle dazzle ship on it or one that says always read the plaque, go to 99pi.org and click the link that says shop. And you can show off your great taste and radio programs and associated merchandise.
出自Arxan的办公室，这是一家非常重视合作的建筑公司，他们甚至可以在没有阿道夫·苏特罗的情况下工作。如果你想要更多关于设计的酷知识或深夜里的随机笑话，试着在Facebook、Tumblr和Twitter上找到我们，但如果你是成千上万因为错过Kickstarter而懊恼的人之一，并且想要一件带有炫目战舰图案的《99%隐形》T恤，或者一件写着“总是阅读牌子”的T恤，请访问99pi.org并点击标有“商店”的链接。你可以展示你对广播节目和相关商品的绝佳品味。
The dazzle ship t-shirt is guaranteed to start at least one conversation a day. Guaranteed, click shop at 99bi.org. Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
炫目战舰T恤保证每天至少能开启一次对话。保证，点击99pi.org的商店。Radio Tapio。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。